[Music]
believe it or not it was a year ago
today that BuzzFeed released the now
infamous Trump dossier and now a year
later they are being sued for defamation
by the president's lawyer
editor-in-chief Ben Smith the BuzzFeed
news will join us later in the show to
defend his decision to publish that
dossier
but first tonight President Trump has
suggested he did yesterday that he's
willing to sign any deal on docker that
Congress is able to hammer out one
actual deal does at this point seem a
long way off but maybe getting a little
closer today House Republicans outlined
a bill that would allow daca
beneficiaries to remain in the United
States critically though it would deny
them a path to citizenship Democrats
don't seem in favor of it they know of
course that amnesty for illegal
immigrants is crucial to their own
electoral strategy of importing a new
class of voters from abroad Democratic
congressman from Texas beta O'Rourke
represents the border city of El Paso
he's seeking the Democratic nomination
to challenge Senator Ted Cruz this fall
her work has sponsored legislation that
would provide the illegal immigrants
with taxpayer-funded health care and
free legal assistance to fight
deportation congressman Roark joins us
thanks a lot for coming on thanks for
having me so if you're watching at home
if you're a voter watching this debate
here you have the Republicans conceding
that daca recipients can stay in the
country they're not going to be deported
and you have Democrats responding by
saying no that's not enough we want to
make sure that they can vote and bring
their relatives over also so can you
understand how some people watch that
might conclude the Democrats are
spending more time and energy worrying
about people here illegally than about
American citizens I guess I don't make
the connection Tucker I think that most
Americans most Texans certainly those
that I've listened to across the state
want to make sure that dreamers can
continue to remain and thrive in their
communities you have people like
Savannah Freese who I just met who's a
PhD student in mathematical biology and
Texas Tech she's a dreamer you have
people like Alonzo Guillen who died
trying to rescue his fellow Texans
during the the flooding after Harvey he
was a dreamer from Lufkin Texas I was in
book write as Republican as it gets in
and the people in Booker were concerned
about dreamers because they had just
deported one of the honor roll students
okay I stopped your speech really quick
there are a lot of good dreamers for
sure there are also a lot of bad ones
more dreamers have been busted for gang
membership that have joined the military
I'm not you know that's not an
indictment of all people here under daca
it's just let's just get real these are
normal people some good some bad they're
not all valedictorians but the question
is there are a lot of good American
citizens as well and can you see why
when the Democrats say we're not going
to fund the government unless you allow
these people to vote and bring their
relatives with them that maybe it
suggests a priority that's out of sync
with those of most people here that's my
only question yeah I guess I don't see
that I'll tell you that from my
perspective in El Paso Texas the city
that I represent where I'm raising my
three kids who are 11 9 and 7 I want to
make sure that our community continues
to thrive and one of the reasons that we
are one of the safest cities in America
every single year for the last 20 years
is we're a city of immigrants including
dreamers who contribute to our success
and our safety and that benefit is
spread out over everybody in my
community throughout the state of Texas
and to this country so it's very good
for America not just for dreamers not
just for their families so I think
mostly benefit right I just checked the
school numbers in El Paso the city that
you're bragging about it I passed was a
great city but 39 percent only 39% of
graduating seniors from your schools are
ready for college in math or English it
seems like maybe that's a bigger crisis
than whether or not people here
illegally can bring their relatives from
abroad wouldn't you think I'm gonna get
priorities yeah I don't think working on
these things is mutually exclusive
you'll you'll find no one who's worked
harder or done more for example for
veterans in this country when it comes
to mental health care access that's a
very sacred priority of mine I've been
able to make progress with Republican
members on this issue at the same time I
can advocate for the success of my
community and our country at large by
ensuring that those dreamers stay here
by anyone's measure there's
extraordinary positive economic benefit
to those dreamers staying or the jobs
that are created the dollars are spent
I'm sorry that's done you don't have the
numbers on that you
prove that I've spent a lot of time on
this question you don't actually because
this has been looked at a lot and
there's no evidence that bringing people
who have lower than average educational
attainment as they do into this country
and a high-tech economy makes the rest
of us richer there's just not evidence
for that
yeah well economists have looked at this
and it's measured not in the millions
but in the tens of billions of dollars
to the positive the dreamers bring to
our economy so let me ask you I mean
it's a lot of these are miners that
these are extrapolations in theoretical
I hope you'll can see that at least but
let me ask you this why is it good for
Americans why should Americans pay for
legal representation for people here
illegally you sneak in taxpayers pay for
your lawyer you sponsored legislation
that would allow that how does that
benefit Americans exactly I think it's
keeping true to who we are when you have
asylum seekers from the most violent
brutal countries in the world like El
Salvador who are young kids or young
families I want to make sure that they
have every opportunity to apply for
asylum in this country knowing the laws
having an advocate and aren't returned
to a country where they face in some
cases certain death but they're people
just to be clear there came here
illegally they didn't they didn't come
as refugees through one of our many
programs to bring refugees here very
often I came as asylum seekers who
presented themselves to Border Patrol
agents at the border to customs officers
at the ports of entry
taxpayers are paying for them to fight
American law in court I mean can you see
what American law actually to get right
with American law to make sure that they
show up to their court hearings to make
sure that they follow our laws I think I
think again that's in everyone's
interest but if you're concerned about
secure to pay for lawyers so they can
fight deportation that's somehow good
for us why is it good for us to pay for
the health care bills of people who
snuck in here against our law why did
you sponsor legislation that would have
allowed that to it's good for people who
are in our country who are contributing
to this country's success to be safe to
be healthy to be able to continue to
contribute specified did your bill
specify it only applied to people who
were benefiting our country I don't
think it did I think was anybody
here illegally would get free health
care at taxpayer expense well I I'm
sorry without respect I'm confused by
why we should pay for the health care of
someone who broke our law to get here
does that make sense
yeah I don't think you're reading the
the bill correctly and I think I think
you're losing sight of the benefit that
we gain by those who are contributing to
our communities our state's in our
country's success did that law specify
that only people contributing to our
country would get free health care it
also applied up I don't know gang
members or vagrants I think they go
recover too or thing I think there's an
interest in making sure that if someone
is going to be sick if someone needs
help that we deliver it in the most
efficient effective cost effective way
possible so cost effective to pay for
the health care of people yeah I mean
you can pay for it in the emergency room
but not paying for it at all yeah well
then you can watch people die in your
must be a mean person for not being in
favor congressman thank you for joining
us